- Graduates of the Class of 2020,
family members and friends.
It's a privilege to be
able to speak with you,
even in this unusual way.
I know you would rather be on
campus and I wish you could be
here, but I'm glad we can
all do our part to reduce
the transmission of
COVID-19 and stay healthy.
Over the past several
months, the novel coronavirus
has spread around the globe,
infecting millions and
claiming far too many lives.
It has come to nearly every community.
It has come here to Yale's doorstep.
This crisis has been a
wake-up call for all of us.
It has stretched healthcare
systems to the breaking point.
It has threatened economies,
both household and global.
And like many tragedies, it
has exposed the vast gulf
between the most fortunate
and the most vulnerable.
Long after the pandemic
itself has subsided,
we will need to commit ourselves
to finding new and creative
solutions to these long-term problems.
It may be too early to
say what we have learned
from all of this,
but at the least we see
more sharply than before
our interdependence as a human community.
Our deep levels of connection
and need for one another
are a weakness that
infectious diseases exploit,
but our interdependence is
also a source of strength
and vitality in uncertain times.
Indeed, all of the time.
Many of us has found
inspiration in the sacrifices
of frontline hospital
and healthcare workers,
in the commitment of essential staff,
and in the contributions
of public health experts
and legions of volunteers.
All around us we have seen ordinary people
transformed into heroes.
What does it mean to be called to heroism,
to step out of your normal life
and do something extraordinary?
How do we know if we will
respond to such a call?
Perhaps the most famous story
of this kind is the parable
of the good Samaritan.
You're probably familiar with it.
A man is traveling along the
road when he has attacked
by robbers who leave him for dead.
Three men pass by.
The first two were men of high standing,
ignore the injured man.
The third man, a Samaritan, a
social outcast, stops to help.
He tends to the dying man's wounds,
puts him on his own donkey
and takes him to an inn
where he pays for his stay.
He even tells the
innkeeper he will come back
and pay for anything else the man needs.
The Samaritan is a true
neighbor to the dying man
and he is the unexpected
hero of the parable.
One of the classic studies from my field
of social psychology
takes the good Samaritan
as its jumping off point.
In the 1970s, two psychologists
conducted an experiment
to understand why people help or don't.
They chose a group of seminary
students who were studying
to be ministers.
The students were told they needed to go
to a nearby building to
prepare sermons on what else?
The parable of the good Samaritan.
Then they were divided into three groups.
The first group was told
they had plenty of time
before they needed to be
at the other building.
The second group was
told they needed to hurry
or they'd be late,
and the third group was
told they were already late
and really needed to hurry.
So we have all these different
students on their way to work
on their sermons,
presumably with the good
Samaritan on their minds,
but as they're walking between buildings,
each encounters someone
needing help, actors of course,
but pretending to be very ill or hurt.
In some cases,
the actor was lying on the sidewalk,
and the seminary students had
to physically step over him
to get by.
The researchers wanted to
know who would stop to help.
Well, not many,
although two-thirds of
the people who thought
they were early stopped to help,
fewer than half of those
who are told they were
just on time did so.
Worst of all, only 10%
of the seminary students
who thought they were late
took the time to check
on the hurt person.
That means 90% of those students thought
it was more important to
rush to work on their sermons
about the good Samaritan
than to take care of someone
who is sick or hurt and alone.
Maybe this was the real
lesson of the parable.
As the researchers pointed out,
perhaps the first two
men were not bad people.
They just had busier schedules.
So how busy are we?
Are we too busy to be neighbors?
If nothing else, that much has changed
in the past few months.
Faced with a global pandemic
of staggering scope,
we have had to slow down.
We have adjusted our
lives and our expectations
and I believe we have
seen a bit more clearly
what is meaningful and essential.
Perhaps too we have seen our neighbors,
but in some ways we face an
even greater challenge now
than the one the good Samaritan
or the seminary students faced.
They couldn't help but
see their neighbors.
They were right on their path.
But in trying to contain
the spread of COVID-19,
we've had to act with concern
for people we don't know
and may never see.
We've had to think about
neighbors who are very real
but also very abstract.
We have been forced to reimagine
who and where our neighbors are.
When this crisis is
over, this is the lesson
I hope we carry with us,
that we must act with
urgent concern and
compassion for the neighbors
we know personally and those we do not,
for people down the street
and for those on the
other side of the globe.
For COVID-19 is not the
only pandemic we will face.
It is not the only
challenge you will tackle.
Yes, there will be other
infectious diseases,
other public health challenges,
but I'm thinking too of
different kinds of pandemics.
Right now our neighbors around the world
are already experiencing
the deadly effects
of climate change.
They are living through
extreme weather events
and rising sea levels.
Scientists tell us with
confidence that these conditions
will only get worse unless we
take drastic action to slow
the warming of our planet.
The lives we save tomorrow
depend on our actions today.
What else threatens the
health and wellbeing
of the human family?
What about the pandemic of poverty?
The illness of inequality?
Will we act in time or ignore the problem?
These are questions we
must answer together.
Our interdependence can
be a source of strength,
but only if we agree to look beyond
our immediate line of sight,
only if we learn how to see our neighbors.
Today I can say with
confidence that the world is
full of neighbors and heroes.
I think of Chaney Kalinich a
2019 graduate of Yale College
who has joined others in
our community to volunteer
with the New Haven Medical Reserve Corps.
Chaney is working with some
of the city's most vulnerable
residents while completing
her Master's degree
at the School of Public Health
where she is helping develop
a program to track COVID-19
in the State.
I think of a group of current
Yale College students who
started a company to
connect senior citizens
with phones, tablets, and other devices
so that they can keep up with
their doctor's appointments
via telemedicine.
These students are working with volunteers
across the country, and
they recently delivered
a shipment of devices to patients
at the West Haven VA Medical Center.
Across this city and region,
countless individuals are
steering us through this crisis.
Healthcare and other
essential workers are risking
their own health and
wellbeing to care for others.
Scientists are working long
hours to understand the disease.
First responders, members
of the National Guard
and volunteers are distributing
foods to those in need.
On this campus our remarkable
staff and faculty members
have made so many changes
and sacrifices to ensure
the best outcomes for our
students and this community.
And you, members of the Class
of 2020, in the midst of
unprecedented circumstances,
you have demonstrated concern
for your neighbors, near and far.
You have made great personal
sacrifices to protect others.
You've given up big moments,
recitals, performances,
and championship games.
You have have missed in person
classes and year-end rituals.
And you have also missed quieter moments,
meals and conversations,
walks with friends through old
campus and down Chapel Street.
Yet in the face of
disappointment and hardship,
you have remained
committed to your studies.
You have continued to
invent, imagine and create.
You have stayed connected with
friends and family members.
You have rejected isolation
in favor of community.
You have strengthened the
ties that bind us together
as a university and as a human family.
And today, I encourage you to
think of the good Samaritan
in a new light, not how
great or amazing he was,
but how ordinary he was.
Life calls each of us,
average human beings,
to acts of extraordinary courage.
These are no ordinary times.
The world needs each of you,
prepared to tackle whatever
challenges come your way.
I am confident, with eyes open and hearts
full of compassion, you
will take Yale's mission
of light and truth to
neighbors near and far.
Members of the Class of 2020,
on behalf of the entire Yale
community, faculty,
students, staff and alumni,
we salute your accomplishments.
We are proud of your achievements.
Remember to give thanks for
all that has brought you
to this day and go forth
with grateful hearts
and helpful hands, ready
to lead and serve a world
that needs your talents,
gifts, and caring spirit,
now more than ever.
Congratulations, Class of 2020.